so we have this equation right over here
12 to the negative two power times one
over 72 to the fifth power is equal to
two to the a power times three to the b
power
and what i want you to do now is pause
this video and find values of a and b
that satisfy this equation where a and b
are two integers and i encourage you to
use all of the exponent properties that
we have now learned in order to tackle
this
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so now we can work through this together
so what i'm going to try to do is get
these numbers like 12 and these numbers
like 72 i want to express them as
products of powers of two and powers of
three
so 12 for example
is equivalent to three times four
so i could write this as 3
times 4 and all of that is going to be
raised to the negative 2 power now why
am i interested in 3 times 4 well 3 is
clearly a power of 3 and 4 is clearly a
power of 2. this is 2 squared and we're
actually going to write it as 2 squared
in a second so this is 3 times 4 to the
negative 2 power and then 1 over 72
1 over 72 could be rewritten as so it's
going to be times 1 over
8 times
9. 72 is 8 times 9. 8 is a power of 2.
9 is a power of 3. and of course we're
going to raise that to the 5th
power and that's going to be equal to 2
to the a times 3 to the b and i'm just
gonna i'm just going to keep trying to
simplify the left hand and then we'll tr
in terms of powers of 2 and 3 and then
see if we can if we can match what a and
b need to actually be equal to
so let's look at this right over here so
this if we have the product of two
numbers raised to an exponent we know
from our exponent properties that this
is going to be
the each of those numbers raised to the
exponent the product of that or the
product of each of those numbers raised
to that exponent so it's going to be 3
to the negative 2
times
times 4
to the negative 2 power
times 4 to the negative 2 power and now
this right over here before let me just
rewrite it like this this is going to be
the same thing
times
1 over
1
over
let me write it this way times
1 over 8
times 1 over 9 and we're going to raise
that to the 5th power
now 3 to the negative 2 we could just
keep as 3 to the negative 2. that seems
like a nice form to leave it in so let
me write that as 3 to the negative 2
power
now what is 4 to the negative 2 power
well 4
let me introduce a new color here 4 is
the same thing as 2 squared so it's
going to be times 2 squared
to the negative 2 power 2 squared to the
negative 2 power now what is 1 over 8
what is 1 8
1 8 you could view this as 8 to the
negative 1 power or you could view this
as 1 over 2 to the third power which is
the same thing as 2
to the negative 3 power and these are
consistent because remember 8 is the
same thing as 2 to the third so this is
2 to the third to the negative 1 power
which is 2 to the 3 times negative 1
which is 2 to the negative 3 power
so 1 8 is 2 to the negative 3rd power
and by that same logic
1 9
1 9 is equal to
9 to the negative 1 power or you could
view it as 1 over 3 squared which is
equal to 3 to the negative 2. and these
once again are consistent because 9 is 3
squared and you're raising it to the
negative 1 power so once again that's 3
to the 2 times negative 1 3 to the
negative 2 power so this is going to be
equal to
but we're raising everything to the
fifth power
so
1 8 we just established is the same
thing
1 8 we just i can't have any trouble
changing colors 1 8 we just established
is 2 to the negative 3 power and 1 9
1 9 i'm running out of colors
1 9 is 3
is 3 to the negative
2
power
so let's keep simplifying this we have
our 3 to the negative 2 3 to the
i feeling i'm going to need some space
so 3 to the negative 2 power
now this part right over here i can
introduce purple again
that part that's 2 to the second power
and then that raised to the negative 2
power well we've already seen that's the
same thing as taking 2
to the product of these two exponents 2
times negative 2 is negative 4
power
and then we're going to take each of
these we've already seen taking the
product of two numbers and raising it to
an exponent that's the same thing of
taking each of those raising it to the
exponent or taking the product of each
of those raised to that exponent so it's
going to be times
2 to the negative 3
raised to the fifth power
times we're in the home stretch
times 3 to the negative 2
raised to the 5th power
so once again this is going to be 3 to
the negative 2
times 2 to the negative 4. i think you
see the n now
and now what is this 2 to the negative 3
to the 5th and then that raised to the
5th well we multiply these two exponents
that's going to be 2 to the negative 15
times 2 to the negative 15th power
and then what is this going to be
negative 2 times 5 is negative 10. so
this is going to be 3 to the negative
10th
3 to the negative 10th power and so
what's this going to be equal to
well if we multiply the this one let me
do this in a new color if we multiply 3
to the negative 2 times 3 to the
negative 10 we have the same base we
would add the exponents so that's going
to be 3 to the negative 2 plus negative
10 which is the negative 12 power
and then we have a 2 to the negative 4
times 2 to the negative 15. that's going
to be 2 to the
negative 19th power 2 to the negative
19th power and we want that to be equal
to 2 to the a now we go to the beginning
going back to our equation we want that
to be equal to
we want that to be equal to whoops
we're going to want we want that to be
equal to 2 to the a times 3 to the b
well we have 2 to the negative 19 power
so let's let a equal to negative 19 a
equals negative 19
and
we have 3 to the negative 12 so let's
set b is equal to b is equal to negative
12. and we are done so all we did this
was just a an aggressive and aggressive
application of pretty much all of the
exponent properties that we actually
know and it's actually kind of a
satisfying problem